okay good morning so we finished Dante
today and this will be our last session
uh before the
semester uh breaks we'll come back in a
month and we'll start the second
semester second semester um will be very
exciting we are going to do the Crusades
we're going we're going to do secret
societies we'll do um um basically the
rest of human history okay so before we
begin let's review what we learned last
class okay the first first um point is
that there are secrets Mysteries and
paradoxes embedded into Dante's Divine
Comedy and the ultimate secret of the
universe is that we are in God and
God um is in us and that's the ultimate
secret and it breaks apart the idea of
the Holy Holy Trinity remember the idea
of the Holy Trinity is that it's an
equation that makes God exclusive from
us and at the end of Divine Comedy Dante
inserts us back into God which turns the
equation back into a story a story that
we are empowered to write okay and it
creates the idea of
infinity um the idea behind this and
this goes back to Homer is for Dante
love is the unifying force of the
universe remember that God is the force
within us that enables us to love and
connect with others and then the
imagination is the animating force of
the
universe the more we love the more we
can
imagine and it is our responsibility it
is our Legacy it is our gift that we are
able to imagine the universe and
continue the work of God and the prime
example of this is of course Dante what
inspires Dante to create the universe
that is the Divine Comedy is his love
for
beus it is
uncreated uh they never got married they
never consumated their love in fact
beatric died uh when she was very young
but Dante never forgot about her and it
was this love for d
uh sorry it was this love for beatric
that would um Inspire him to create the
Divine Comedy which is um the greatest
literary achievement in human history
and as we discuss the second point is
that the Divine Comedy it is
historically significant because it
becomes inal blueprint for the
Renaissance for the Protestant
Reformation and the Sonic
Revolution and then you ask yourself
wait a minute here when I read the
Divine Colony I don't really understand
what's going on so how did it come to be
so historically significant and the
answer is this the answer is that it is
poetry and poetry is a is a unique form
of writing poetry is meant to be
memorized
okay so um the way you learn the way you
that you're educated for thousands of
years in uh Western his in Western
history is through the memorization of
classical poets so remember the Greeks
how did they educate themselves they
memorize Homer the Romans memorize
Virgil and the Italians memorize
Dante um and poetry is uniquely designed
in order to be
memorized and so that's the first step
and then the second step is this think
of
poetry as a superfood for the
brain you are what you
eat and your brain thinks the way that
it has consumed
information and so poetry is this
extremely dense nutritious food that the
brain will um use in order to formulate
its understanding of the
world
okay and what's really um interesting is
the brain
actually works 99% subconsciously
meaning we are not consciously aware of
what the brain is doing most of the time
and what the brain is doing most of the
time is trying to figure out the
patterns of the universe the brain does
not like paradoxes it does not like
Mysteries it doesn't like it doesn't
like contradictions okay so it's always
trying to resolve these contradictions
in order to formulate a coherent
understanding of the world that's why
Paradox is so powerful within the Divine
Colony with as we discussed last class
the Divine Kony is full of paradoxes
which forces your brain to conciously
work to resolve these
paradoxes um the greatest Paradox within
the Divine Colony as we discussed last
class is a fact that we are within
God and that creates a paradox for the
brain to slowly resolve and once it
resolves it formulates a new
understanding of the
world and because of that this new
understanding will become the
Renaissance brain the scientific brain
which will power the rise of modernity
okay does that make
sense and so the third point the most
important point
is what Dante realized when he wrote The
Divine Comedy is he if is that if he has
to created a new modern brain if he has
to create a new scientific romantic mind
then his true enemy is actually not
Augustine okay it is actually
Virgil because at this time every
educated
individual um was educated through
Virgil it was Virgil is understanding
the world that captured the imagination
of the European mind and so Dante when
he writes The Divine Comedy his mission
is to supplant Virgil it is to remove
Virgil from the brain the mind of the
European he basically needs to he
basically needs to um poetically do
surgery okay and the way and so what
I'll do is this first I'll explain the
thesis and explain what he's trying to
do and then we'll study the Divine
common to see how he does that okay so
the the so Dante understands that if
Virgil has become the basis of your mind
okay if the
inad um is the way that people
fundamentally understand the world you
cannot get go into an open conflict with
Virgil because people will just reject
you right people will choose their
Customs their
habits first and so if you threaten
their uh habits and Customs then they
will see you as a threat they will
reject you so Dante has to
perform um surgery on the brain that is
nuanced and subtle and sophisticated
okay and the way he does this
the way he does that it's very
clever Dante makes his arch nemesis
Virgil the
hero of the Divine
Comedy okay Virgil is the guide the
narrator the protagonist of the Divine
Comedy what happens is that we start off
with Dante the poet lost in the
woods and it's a symbol or metaphor for
his midlife prises he doesn't know where
he's going uh he's confused by the world
and suddenly Virgil appears before him
and says I am Virgil a poet and I've
been sent by the lady beus from Heaven
to guide you through infernal and
through per through Purgatory where you
will learn the secrets of the universe
where where you will learn the truth
about the world and I am your guide I
will tell you the truth okay so right
from the start we learned that Virgil is
the hero the guide
that's the first thing that happens and
the second thing that happens is Dante
turns him into an
unreliable guide we will discover that
Virgil does not speak the truth in fact
Virgil contradicts himself all the
time and the third thing that will
happen is Virgil over time will become
displaced by
other figures including
beus all right so it is one of the
greatest literary
tricks where Dante understands Virgil
his his ultimate Nemesis and in order to
defeat Virgil he makes Virgil the hero
of this epic okay does that make
sense all right so it's the idea of the
unreliable narrator
all right so we're going to study some
passages from Divine Comedy to see how
Dante does this and it's very clever
it's almost impossible to spot unless
you recognize what Dante is trying to do
okay once I tell you what he's doing
it's then as obvious but again if you
were to read Divine Comedy by yourself
you wouldn't notice it okay but again
the brain works subconsciously the brain
will slowly over time pick pick up these
problems with Virgil and construct a new
worldview that is anti- uh Virgil and
pro Dante okay that's a trick of the
Divine Comedy any questions before I
continue are we clear all right so all
right so Virgo and Dante are now going
to explore in The Inferno hell and they
first end up in in limbo okay and limbo
is the outer circle of hell and it's a
very nice place it's not Paradise it's
not great it's still part of hell but
it's a place specifically for virtuous
pagans who were born before the time of
Jesus you can only be saved by Jesus if
you were baptized into the faith and so
if unfortunately you were born before
the time of Jesus you put in limbo and
that's
where uh Virgil is okay so Virgil
explains
to uh Dante the kindly Master Okay so
there are all these encomiums for Virgil
Virgil is the father to Dante Virgil is
the master to Dante all right do do you
not ask who are the spirits whom you see
before you I'd have you know before you
go ahead they not sin okay these people
are virtuous including himself these are
are people who include Plato um
Homer um Julius Caesar okay these
individuals are are
virtuous though they have merits that's
not enough because they like baptism
okay the fundamental rule of Heaven is
you have to be baptized into the faith
the portal of the faith that you Embrace
and if they live before Christianity
they did not worship God in fitting ways
and of such spirits I myself am one okay
this is why I'm here in limbo I am as
virtuous as can be but because I was not
baptising the
faith I am stuck here okay of course
this raises a question because Dante has
nothing but
questions and D asks him this
question is this an iron law of the
universe or were there exceptions okay
so we have asked did any ever go by his
own Merit or others from this place
towards blessedness were they able to
ascend into heaven based on his or her
own individual struggle and Merit and
this is what virtual
says there was only one time in the
entire history of the universe when it
was possible for people in limbo to sent
into heaven and that was the death of
Jesus Christ remember that he was
crucified then he died before he was
resurrected and then when he died he
ascended into The Inferno and while he
was there he took the most virtuous
members of the Bible okay who
include um Abel Adam Noah Moses Abraham
David Israel he took all of them into
heaven but that was it okay and that was
a rare event right because Jesus God
only dies once but that's it all right
and so that's what Virgil is
saying okay so now that they've been
through Limbo what they're going to do
is they're going into the inner circles
of hell and the first circle of hell are
reserved for those who died who s
because of love because of lust okay and
what's going to happen is that there's
going to be parade of all these Souls
these spirits who are burning in hell
because they died For Love or lust they
sinned out of love all right so um the
first of those about whose history you
want to know my master told me once we
as empress over many nations her Vice of
lust became so customary that she made
license listed in her laws to free her
from the Scandal she had
caused she is samaris of whom we read
that she was n's wife and his successor
okay that's the first person they see
she held the land the sultan Now
commands all right but now there's a
second person the other Spirit killed
herself for love and she betrayed the
ashes of psychas the W Cleopatra follows
next all right so this this is
interesting what's going to happen is
there there'll be about a thousand
spirits who are parading before Dante
and Virgil and what's interesting is
that Virgil names every one of them
except this person the other Spirit
killed herself for love and she betrayed
the ashes of psychi this person her name
is
ditto who is didto didto is from the
inad right
she is the liter
creation of Virgil this is really
interesting because why is didle in the
infernal because Virgil put her
there and not only does he put her there
he does not even bother to acknowledge
and name her this is a complete contrast
to the relationship between Dante and
beus now um when you actually read the
inad what you discover is that there's
only one realistic
character in The Epic and it's stto the
way that she
behaves um her love for in
inas it's actually it actually makes her
her sympathetic character but it's her
love for inas that causes her to
uh to
die okay and so who is did who is didle
really well if she's a liter
creation of
virgils I can guess we can surmise that
ditto must have
existed and ditto is someone who
possibly could have um spited Virgil
right and that's why Virgil has such
venom for
her right remember in the indad didle
dies by fling herself into a funeral P
okay she Burns herself to to death it's
a terrible way to die and she
dies um driven into Madness by love so
you can almost make the argument that
you can
surmise Virgil really hates this person
and she wanted he wanted to punish her
for refusing him in real life and this
is interesting for us bis go this is
dally opposed to what Dante did right
Dante loved beatric but he could not he
could not possess PC so what he does is
he's creates the Divine Harmony so that
PC can be in Paradise for the rest of
her for all of eternity okay this is D
dally opposed so right away in the from
this we can understand that Dante and
Virgil have opposing perspectives on
love these are not friends these are
enemies all right now let's
continue Virgil refuses to name ditto
okay but what Dante will do is name
ditto okay those Spirits let the ranks
where D suffers where didle suffers
Virgil you refuse to acknowledge your
creation but I will because she deserves
our
Mercy she deserves our charity and our
generosity so you can see how within the
Poetry there's this massive conflict
going on between Virgil and Dante and
it's all very subtle
okay okay
now they go through Inferno and they end
up in purgatory Purgatory is this
isolated Mountain that is the halfway
point between Inferno and Paradise
people have to send the P Purgatory in
order to um get into
um Paradise okay and this the these are
the first lines of purgatory I saw a
solitary patriarch near me his aspect
worthy of such reverence that even son
to Father owes no more okay this person
is
Kato Kato is a Roman patriarch who
opposed Julius Caesar and when julus
julus Caesar was about to win the civil
war KO killed himself he committed
suicide rather than submit
to Julius
Caesar now what's interesting about
about this is that Kato and virtue are
contemporaries they knew each other in
Rome and when they died they went to
limbo right what's interesting is this
where's K now Kato is in
purgatory he's left he's left limbo he's
left
Inferno and not only that but he's
become the guardian of purgatory he's
the one who controls access into
purgatory so Virgil is wrong remember
Virgil said it's impossible possible to
leave limbo regardless of your Merit and
this right away tells us no Virgil is
not a reliable narrator Kato has left
okay now you would imagine that because
Kato
and Virgil know each other they're like
good friends okay
so Virgil so k say to Virgil and Don
like who are you to how are you able to
escape from from hell okay and then
Virgil says let me do the talking
because I know this guy okay we're
friends
right I do not come through my own self
there's a lady Sent From Heaven okay
this lady is beist her please let me to
help and guide this man but since your
will would have a far more full and
accurate account of her condition my
will cannot withhold what you request
you want to know why we're here let me
explain to you why we're
here this man had yet to see his final
evening he's not dead but through his
folly little time was left before he did
he was so close to it he was facing a
midlife crisis as I've told you I was
sent to him for his Deliverance the only
Road I could have taken was the road I
took I had to take him through hell okay
and that's why we're here I showed them
all the people of predition now I in
tend to show him to him those spirits
who in your care remember C is the
guardian of purgatory are B on
experation okay so people are here in
purgatory in order to absolve themselves
of their sins so they that they may
Ascend into
heaven now this is what what ver Virgil
says to KO you know it who in utaka
found death for Freedom was not bitter
when you left the gar that will be
bright on the great day so I know who
you are you're KO you're the person who
killed himself in UDA rather than submit
to the tyranny of Julius Caesar Eternal
adicts are not broken for us this man's
alive and I'm not bound by myos but I am
from the circle where the chase eyes of
your Marcia your wife are I know your
wife and she still prays to you oh holy
breast to keep her as your own for her
love then inclined to us remember Marcia
your
wife allow our journey for your seven
Realms I shall thank her for kindness
you bestow if you would let your name be
named below so what Virgil is doing is
saying to KO listen you may be the
guardian of purgatory this is your your
master of this realm but I have power in
hell so I'm going to go back and I'm
going to be nice to your wife Marcia
right so give me some face here man you
know and this is what K says while I was
there within the other world Marcus so
pleased my eyes he then replied Each
Kindness required I satisfied now that
she dwells beyond the evil River she has
no power to move me any longer such was
the law decreed when I was freed so KO
is upset with
this K says to Virgil how dare you bribe
me how dare you do this
Marcia is back
in limbo which means she is no longer as
pure in my eyes as I used to
think if I'm able to ascend into
purgatory based on my own Merit then so
was Marcia and if she's not if if she's
not able to come with me that mean that
means she's not as virtuous as I once
thought okay so you can see right away
that Virgil is not reliable
he has no authority over k k does not
respect him even though they're they
they know each other very well okay does
that make sense again this is very very
clever it's almost impossible to see
unless I tell you what's
happening
okay all
right now the question then
is what
makes virtuo so unreliable what is his
problem and what Donnie will will reveal
to us is it's really Virgil's conception
of love that's the
issue okay remember Virgil is someone
who condemn didto into hell and it is
Dante
who sent beus into heaven okay so these
people have these two individuals have
radically radically opposing conceptions
of love so let's
so we know what Dante thinks about love
okay love is the god for is the god
Force within us that connects us with
God and the entire universe and the more
that we love the more imaginative we
will be okay so so you have to direct
this love at someone but it doesn't
really matter that person loves you back
that's not relevant okay what relevant
is that you
love so let's look at Virgil's
understanding of love
the soul which is quick to love responds
everything that pleases just as soon as
Beauty wakens it to act okay so the
first thing we we have to understand is
that we are animals with Souls that
respond to Beauty if I see a beautiful
woman across the street I stop and I
chase her
okay that's the first thing he says your
apprehension draws an image from a real
object and expands upon that object
until until Soul has turned toward it
but then you're like but you don't know
this beautiful woman and what virgal
says is what happens next is your
imagination will take over and you will
turn this woman into a fantasy
woman that you can now
control okay so let's go back to the
example from last class where you meet
this beautiful woman and you say I want
to marry you because you're you're so
beautiful and she says I will if you
give me 10
now if you think about it she's clearly
saying no to
you but it is your imagination that
tricks you into believing that as long
as you give her $10 million she will
love you okay her love is something that
you can master and control and
possess and if Soul turn the soul T
steadfastly then that propensity is love
it's nature that joins a soul in you a
new through Beauty okay you must possess
her you will do you will do everything
possible in order to to possess her and
that's what love is all right you you
see someone beautiful you turn her into
a
fantasy and then you chase after this
fantasy until it's yours that's what
love
is then just as flames Ascend because
the form of fire was fashioned to fly up
word toward the stuff to its own spear
where it lasts longer okay so you can
understand that what Virgil uses is lot
of natural imagery okay fire so these
are things beyond our control right we
are consumed by our lust and our love
for this woman so does the soul when
sees move into longing emotion of the
spirit never resting till the belov
thing has made it joyous we have to
possess it if we don't possess it then
we will be
depressed now you can plainly see how
deeply hidden truth is from scrutinous
who would insist that every love is in
itself praiseworthy okay there's some
people who believe that love is
beautiful no no no it depends on who you
love okay and they are led to error by
the matter of love because it may seem
always good but not each seal is fine
although the wax
is okay if you love a woman who loves
you back that's fine but if a woman
insists that you go rob a bank for $10
million then that's bad all
right your speech and my own wi that
follow it I answered him this is Dante
have shown me what love is but that has
filled me with greater doubt for if
Love's offered to us from about and it's
the only foot with which Soul walks Soul
going straight or crooked has no merit
okay this is a really interesting
question if it is true
that when we see someone beautiful we
must have her then we have no free will
we have no free choice we're just all
animals and this is what Virgil
says what Reon can see here I can impart
pass that for truth of Faith it's beus
alone you must await every substantial
form at once distinct from matter and
conjoin to it and gathers the force that
is distinctively its own
a force unknown to us until it acts it's
never shown except in its effects just
as green bous displayed the life in
plants so it is true that our soul wants
to possess things that are beautiful
okay that's what that's what love is and
thus man does not know the source of his
intelligence or Primal Notions and his
tending towards desires Primal objects
okay so we are not aware of the lust
within us we are not aware of how our
soul works both are in you just as in
bees there is the honey making urge such
Prim and will deserves no praise it
deserves no blame okay we just lust for
what is beautiful that's just how we are
um
made now that all other longings May
conform to this first will there is in
you inborn the power that counsels keep
of the threshold
of your Ascent this is the principle of
which your Merit may be judged for it
Garners and windows good and evil
longings okay so what we can do our
choice our Free Will in the matter is to
resist our temptation to say no that
that's what Augustine would say right we
just say no no no yes I want her but
it's bad for me so I
will stop myself from doing so
okay but those resers who reach the
roots of things learn of this inborn
Freedom the bequest that thus they left
on to the world is ethics okay even if
we allow necessity as source for every
Power that inflames in you the power to
curve that love is still your own the
power to curb that love is still your
own we can resist we can say no we can
deny our
love there's noal power is what beist
means by Free Will therefore remember it
if she should ever speak of it to you
okay so this is the conception of love
from um Virgil okay does that make
sense love can be good or it can be bad
it's you who must decide if it's bad for
you then you must
resist
okay and so what is Dante's response to
this
argument do you guys
remember what what what's a response to
this okay the response is this the
response is if you truly love someone
then you only want what's best for that
person and so if the person says to you
I will only marry you if you give me $10
million then you know that person
doesn't love you so you turn away from
her and says all I care is about is your
happiness if you're happier without me
then I will leave but I certainly will
not degrade you like by thinking that
you're only worth $10 million to my eyes
you're Priceless and you you only to
grade yourself if you think that you're
only worth $10 million does that make
sense okay so love is not about
possession it's
about respecting
the person for who she is okay does that
make sense
right all right so let's
continue so now they're climbing up the
mountain of
purgatory and Purgatory is an isolated
Mountain okay that there's a force field
around it that protects it from the
natural elements but every now and then
there's an earthquake okay the entire
Mountain trembles and the reason why is
because a soul with that
mountain has cleansed himself or herself
of her sins she's absolved herself of
her sins and therefore here or she now
has access to heaven and the heavens
celebrate this with with a with a shake
okay with an earthquake
so
um Virgil and D and they meet a man
named statius a poet who has just exp
himself okay who's just released himself
from his sins and he's so excited
because he's going to heaven all right
and this this is what he says so had the
will to clim before but that will was
opposed by longing to do Penance as once
to sin instilled by Divine Justice okay
so the people in um Purgatory are those
who have committed a sin and they need
to do Penance before they can go to
heaven now this is really important why
because ask ask youself this question if
hell is a place where people go because
they've Sinn and Purgatory is a place
where people go because they sin what is
the
difference right okay and what what we
will learn is this the difference is the
question of
will people in purgatory recognize that
they have committed a sin and that that
they must do Penance before they go to
heaven but they're willing to admit that
they've committed a sin and they're
willing to do the Penance and the
Penance could be a thousand years it
could be one year it doesn't it doesn't
matter okay but they're willing to
commit themselves to penance hell is a
place where you go because you refuse to
admit you've committed a sin you refuse
to admit your wrong if you refuse to
admit your wrong you can never you can
never do Penance you can never absolve
yourself of your sins and that's the
difference guys that's the only
difference okay in terms of like crime
in terms of sin it's the same but the
difference is those in purgatory have
committed themselves to redeeming
themselves all
right so let's continue and I and this
is stadius by the way who have laid in a
suffering 500 years he's been here 500
years okay and more just now have felt
the My Free Will for a better threshold
thus you have heard the earthquake and
the pious Spirits throughout the
mountain as they praised the Lord and
may he send them speedily upward so if
you are able to release yourself from
your sin you are now there's an
earthquake and you and now you have
access to heaven so did he speak to us
and just as Joy is it's greatest when we
quench a greater thirst The Joy he
brought cannot be told in words status
is the happiest person in the universe
at this point because he has found
paradise and my wife guy and this is um
Virgil I now can see the net impeding
you how one sips through and why it
Quakes here and what makes you all
rejoice and now may it please you to
tell me who you were in your own words
may I find why you've laay here for so
many centuries tell us who you
are okay who are you how you how are you
able to accomplish this in that age when
the worthy Titus with help from the
highest King Avenge the wounds from
which the blood that Judas sold had
flowed okay so this is about 70 and this
and Titus is the Roman general who
attacked Jerusalem sacked it and
destroyed the temple and the Christians
saw this as revenge for the killing of
their Savior Jesus that's sufficient
Fame beyond that Spirit replied I bore
the name that lasts longest and honors
most but Faith was not yet mine okay so
he's trying to explain who he
is so gentle was the spirit of my verse
that Rome drew me son of tus to her and
there were my brow deserve a crown of
Myrtle on Earth my name is still
remember statius I sang of Thieves and
then of great Achilles I fell along the
way of that lost labor okay so he's an
epic poet just like ver
that the Sparks that warmed me the seeds
of my ardor were from the Holy Fire the
same that gave more than a thousand
poets let inflame okay so what inspired
me is the Holy Fire who is the Holy
Fire we would think God right nope it is
Virgil okay I speak of the inad it is
Virgil who is the Holy Fire it is Virgil
who is God when I wrote verse it was
Mother to me it was nerd my work routed
would not weigh an ounce I was inspired
by the inad and Virgil to write my
poetry Virgil is the god the mother who
nursed me and to have lived on earth
when Virgil lived for that I would
extend by one more year the time I owe
before my Exiles end I've been in per
for 500 years but if I had a chance to
meet Virgil I would stay one more year
that's how Virgil that's how how much I
love Virgil that's how much how
important Virgil is to me he doesn't
know that the person standing next to
him is Virgil
okay these words made Virgil turn to me
and as he turned his face his face
through silence said be still okay he's
like shut up man I don't want to know
who who who I
am all right so what's going on here
well what's really important for us to
understand is that this shows us that
Virgil was lying Virgil told us in the
beginning of the of divine colony was
impossible for Meritt to
leave um limbo and Ascend
to Paradise he told us that you have to
be baptized in order to get into heaven
status was not
baptized right status is exactly like
Virgil a Roman epic poet
but status is able to ascend to heaven
but Virgil is
not does that make
sense and the reason why status is able
to go to heaven
is status wants to okay he's willing to
admit there there are flaws in his
thinking he's willing to admit that his
understanding of the world is flawed and
he needs to undergo
introspection reflection to improve
himself Virgil is
not does that make
sense all right so let's go to the very
last passage and we'll and then we'll
end and this is this is Kanto 30 and
this is when beus is ascending from
Heaven okay no she's sorry she's
descending from Heaven on a chariot and
it
is uh and she's beautiful okay and
that's at this point if you're
Virgil you might be like wow this is my
chance to get out of limbo and go to
heaven right because beus who's in
heaven asked me to do her a favor guide
Dante F infernal and Purgatory I've done
that man now she owes me and here's my
chance to say to be hey could you do me
a favor and like get me into heaven
that's all he has to do right that would
make sense
let's see what
happens so this
is beus descending from heaven and Dante
is en raptured okay he's just completely
she completely focused on beus within
her presence I had once been used to
feeling trembling Wonder disolution but
that was long ago still though my soul
now she was veiled could not see her
directly by way of hidden force that she
could move I felt the mighty power of
old love all right so it's been decades
since he last saw her but he still feels
for her he's trembling okay he's
completely en raptured by
beus as soon as that deep Force had
struck my vision the power that when I
had not yet left my B Boyhood had
already transfixed me I turned around
and to my left just as a little child
afraid of in distress will hurry to his
mother anxiously he's turning around who
who does he want to talk to Virgil right
he's he's there are butterflies in his
stomach he's excited he's trembling he
said Virgil Virgil it's beus okay he
sees Virgil as his father he wants to
share his Joy with
Virgil all right and where is
Virgil to say to Virgil I am left with
less than one drop of my blood that does
not tremble I recognize the sons of the
the signs of the old flame Virgil it's
beus I've waited decades for this moment
he wants to share this happiness with
Virgil but Virgil had deprived us of
himself Virgil the gentless father
Virgil he to whom I gave myself for my
salvation Virgil has run
away at this climax at this moment when
Dante is finally reunited with beus
the moment that Virgil has completed his
quest Virgil has run
away okay he's ran he's run away he's
disappeared no one knows knows where he
is and even our ancient mother LW was
not enough to keep my cheeks though
washed with DW from darkening again with
tears what Donnie wants more than
anything else is for a Virg to share his
happiness what he wants more than
anything anything else is for Virgil to
ascend to heaven like Dante
will and Virgil
disappear and
Dante knows at this point Virgil will
never
change Virgil run away because he
refuses to admit he is wrong you
understand once Virgil sees
the love between beus and Dante then
Virgil knows his conception of Love is
wrong because never once did Dante
possess
beatric but never once did Dante stop
loving beatric so love is not about
possession it's about trust it's about
faith that's what love is and so rather
than admit he is
wrong and go to Heaven by the way Virgil
is like screw this I'm going back to
hell because I'm happier
there i' rather burn in hell for
eternity then admit I'm
wrong Dante though Virg leaving you do
not yet weep do not weep yet you'll need
your tears for yet for what another
sword must yet inflict pus says to Dante
let him go let him go you can't save him
you have to save
yourself there's no point in trying to
save those who don't want to be saved it
just
isn't all right and so that this is the
last we will see of Virgil and as you
can understand at this point in our
hearts we've also learned to let Virgil
go and this means that slowly from our
minds the inad will dissipate will
dissolve itself and and we will have a
new memory called The Divine Colony come
into place which will reshape the way we
see the
universe okay does that make sense guys
is this
clear all right any
questions about
this yeah go ahead
it actually goes way back so you got
some keep going no no no no I I'm I'm
finished yeah okay so I'm sorry about
this I was like trying to answer
messages at the same time yeah no
worries no worries
yeah that's
right I I missed that part like how did
he do that
yeah okay so um how did Virgil put title
In Hell okay so this goes back to the
inad um which everyone will have read if
you read the Divine commy you must have
you you will certainly have read um the
inad so what happens in the inad is that
inas a prince of Troy he's going to Rome
to basically found the Roman Empire okay
that is his Divine Mission sent to him
by the gods but along the way he gets
Shipwrecked on Carthage and didle who is
the um queen of Carthage welcomes him
and his people and they fall in love and
then um they get married they have sex
and all that but then the gods get angry
because they didn't want indas in
Carthage they want him in Rome okay so
they sent um Mercury the messenger of
God to tell him hey man inas
go to Rome and in is because he's Pious
okay that's that's what he's famous for
for for being Pious he just basically
says fine okay and didle of course gets
very upset and he and he warns inas if
you leave I I can only kill myself I
love you that much and in is basically
like yeah go kill yourself okay so he
leaves and she kills herself okay she
basically throws herself into a um I I I
can't remember I I I I think she just
stops herself with a sword and then
throws herself off off into a fire okay
so um didle is dead now on the way to
Rome inas has to go through hell in
order to um get a prophecy of the
founding of Rome and in Hell who does he
meet he meets ditto and inas is kind of
it's awkward for him and he's like I
should go say hi okay but the moment he
tries to say hi to ditto d runs away and
what what's happened is that in hell not
only is she burning in hell but she's
lost the power to speak which for the
Greeks and the Romans was was even worse
than death you've lost the power to
speak um so that's what happens in the
inad and um D is continuing this idea in
The Divine Comedy he's assumed that if
if you're if you're reading The Divine
Comedy you've already read the the inad
which which I mean again the inad is
what you have to memorize in
school yeah just wonder with her being
aagan I know she could get out of
hell she would have
been uh that's right just according to
theology yeah so so so yeah so in
Virgil's cosmology dto has to be in hell
because she's she's a pagan and enas is
there as well so enas is actually in
limbo and ditto is the first circle of
of of of hell um the the problem though
is that Virgil does not acknowledge
ditto okay so it's like Virgil wants to
block ditto from her own uh from his own
mind he he he's trying to um ignore the
fact that ditto is is his creation he he
feels kind of embarrassed about about
all
this
okay does that make sense okay
um did you have any questions
yeah oh yeah yeah that's a great
question where do you say is limbo and
patory come from okay so what's
happening is that Don is dealing with an
entire cosmology of Christian thought
okay because throughout Christian
history there have been a lot of
problems one big problem is let's just
say that you're a
baby and you are born before the time of
Christ okay and you die because you're
sick okay well that makes no well then
according to Christian theology then the
baby would burn and
how that's doesn't make any sense right
because because it's a
baby he or she is without sin and he got
unlucky right so they create this place
called Limbo for these special cases
okay does that make sense right so that
that's that's where where with the idea
of limbo from and then
Purgatory is um another idea that was
created um in order to um basically as a
middle ground between hell in heaven
okay because there are lots of special
cases where okay um this person did some
sin and so doesn't can't have access to
heaven but the sin doesn't qualify for
hell right so they created Purgatory so
um The Genius of Dante is he's basically
accessing all this cosmology and like
there are different conflicts within
this cosmology right and he's creating
his own
cosmology right so before Dante the idea
of purgatory was not that common but
after Dante Purgatory became a much more
common Concept in Christian theology
right also what if you actually read the
Divine Colony it's clear that Don is
drawing a lot of his ideas from
narcissism okay so in other words what's
happening is that even though the
Catholic church is trying to impose
Orthodoxy on the European
population most people are actually
resisting especially the educated Elite
they're resisting and they they're
creating their own uh theology in in
opposition to uh the Catholic church so
they they all believe in
Jesus but the interpretation of Jesus is
different
okay so one major difference in the
Divine colony is that um it's Orthodoxy
that Jesus died for our sins but when
beus and Don about Jesus pus tells Dante
no Jesus died to awaken us to educate us
to our own flaws because otherwise we
could not look ourselves in the
mirror okay the death of Jesus was so
shocking that it forced us to look
ourselves in the mirror and to see the
sin within us okay so it was an act of
Education it was an act of inspiration
rather than an act of
redemption okay
according to
Wikipedia was checking this up the uh so
the Catholic Church kind of solidified
its own understanding of
124 Council of so the church gets
together
earlier about the the
ideat B
problem IDE
suffering Mone
get this will be something that
Lu basically 200 years from from the
time this was insed creates a lit
Masterpiece but also kind the to that's
right yeah the um the other thing that
we didn't we discuss is that at this
point in um European history this year
about 1300 right um as Doug says there's
a lot of reflection going on like like
like people in within the Catholic
Church hierarchy understand that
Augustine his theories his theology are
problematic okay
and so what happens is that um a new the
Theologian named Thomas aquinus comes
comes and his Orthodoxy starts to
replace that of Augustine and um a and
aquinus is a much more enlightened much
more open-minded individual than
Augustine is okay they're basically
dealing with two different uh social
Mals when Augustine was around um Rome
was at the height of its power the
Catholic church was an Empire
but obviously a few centuries later
there was the Arabian conquest and there
was the Mongolian Mongolian Conquest as
well so there was a lot of more
self-reflection going on okay and so so
if you look at the ideas of Thomas aqu
quas and Dante they aligned very closely
but what's important for us to
understand is
um philosophy is not as effective as
poetry philosophy is about ideas and you
debate these ideas but poetry goes into
your subconscious and they become the
building blocks of your psyche okay does
that make sense because poetry is
language and and as as we discussed it
was very common back then uh it it was
it was actually a great practice for
just people to memorize poetry they
didn't remember they didn't actually
know what they were memorizing but they
just memorized it and it made them much
more fluent in language and much more
fluid in thought okay and and and that's
that's a culture practice that we no
longer do to our detriment
basically
right shakesp in your
head okay so um are there any more
questions before
we maybe just one like you did plant the
the intriguing idea that the Scientific
Revolution right the seeds of the
Reformation as
well pick up one of those
and right
okay's okay so um the key idea of the
proess Reformation is that you have
direct access to God right um and how do
you access God Through the Bible right
you don't need a priest to be the
middleman because because if there's a
if there's a middleman priest all sorts
of problems are being created corruption
is a huge issue um but also um Orthodoxy
and so the idea of the present
Reformation is that you can access God
through the the Bible
itself okay and why that's and why why
you're able to do that is because God is
within you and within God and there and
therefore through
self-study you're able to access truth
yourself okay so that's the main idea of
the proc
Reformation does that make sense okay
and then when we talk about the silic
revolution the main idea of the silic
revolution is the um in intialization of
Doubt all right what does that mean it
means we incourage you to ask questions
we encourage you to debate because
that's what God wants and where where do
we get this idea from because in heaven
B and D are arguing all the time it's
the vine to ask questions it's divine to
doubt it's divine to
experiment all right um remember the
father of the side of revolution is
Galileo where's Galo from Florence right
so Galo grew up immersed in The Divine
Comedy all right it's these things
aren't AR accidental okay
right all right does that make sense but
but but I will go into these topics and
themes uh much more specifically uh next
semester
okay any more
questions okay great so um I will see
you guys uh next semester that